kampf um das leben von corona patienten
auf dieser intensivstation sind kaum
noch betten frei immer mehr schwer
kranke patienten müssen beatmet und rund
um die uhr versorgt werden
die lage hat denn in der situation ist
nach wie vor wirklich sehr angespannt
allein hier in der städteregion aachen
wo ich mich befinde haben wir aktuell
nur sieben prozent freie betten bilder
gedreht und ausgestrahlt vor einem jahr
heute ist es kaum anders auch im zweiten
krone herbst füllen sich die
intensivstationen
intensivmediziner uwe janssens fürchtet
dass seine station in eschweiler bald
wieder voll ist wie 2020 die krise rückt
näher
in süddeutschland baden württemberg
bayern süd aus bayern habe ja
belegungsraten fasst bis zu 60% 19
anteilig das virus wird sich durch die
einzelne regionen fühlen und dann zu
entsprechenden anteil auf der
intensivstation führen
eine aktuelle modellierung also eine
prognose zeigt die intensivstationen
stehen kurz vor dem kollaps
heute liegt die inzidenz bei 312 steigt
sie weiter bis 400 und kommt das impfen
nicht voran dann müssen im januar 6000
zusätzliche corona intensiv patienten
behandelt werden
diese modellierung zeigt uns eindeutig
und zweifelsfrei welchen unglaublich
wichtigen einfluss im moment neben allen
an maßnahmen die impfungen für die
entwicklung des infektionsgeschehen es
in deutschland haben das krankenhaus
waldfriede in berlin zehlendorf
direktor bernd quaas macht sich sorgen
wie es wohl weitergeht
er muss 15 bis 20 operationen täglich
verschiedenen weil er betten und
pflegepersonal für corona patienten frei
halten muss die lage ist aktuell
dramatisch und wir gehen davon aus dass
durch die für die welle in den nächsten
wochen die situation sich noch
verschärft sollten noch weitere
patienten dazu kommen nicht nur wegen
koma sondern auch gegen andere
erkrankungen müssen wir die
intensivstationen bei der
rettungsleitstelle hier in berlin
abmelden pauli sorgt ist einer von 19
intensiv pflegern im krankenhaus
waldfriede die vergangenen zwei jahre
mit krone haben ihn erschöpft er will
zum jahresende aufhören wegen
überlastung
man hat früher spät nachtdienst und man
hat das dauerhaft und man hat jetzt
nicht unbedingt die große wahl zu sagen
ich mache noch frühdienst ist auch
möglich aber somit familienleben und
allgemeinen sozialleben ist unheimlich
schwierigkeit dass alles so zu
organisieren dass man tatsächlich zu
geburtstagen gehen kann dass man urlaub
planbar machen kann man muss häufig
einspringen weil letztendlich die
station muss laufen und irgendjemand
muss da sein um die patienten zu
versorgen
raphael neu geplant wer wann wie lange
arbeiten muss auf der intensivstation
und muss zurecht kommen damit dass immer
mehr pflege aufhören dieser beruf es hat
nicht darauf ausgelegt wie viele andere
berufe auch dass man bis zum
renteneintritt ganz normal seine acht
stunden hier täglich durch zieht vor
allem oft nicht auf einer
intensivstation
ich glaube das ist eine belastung die
sehen wir auch und diese unfähigkeit
gegen diese belastungen vorzugehen das
ist schon was was man auch abends mit
nach hause nimmt eine krise mit ansage
bereits vor corona klagten viele
intensivpfleger über personalmangel
druck und zu viel arbeit das virus hat
die lage noch mal verschärft
kroner intensivpatienten liegen viel
länger auf der station und brauchen noch
mehr hilfe das hat folgen kritisiert
carsten hermes vom verband der
intensivmediziner
wir haben aktuell roundabout 3000
beatmungs betten die aufgrund von
personalmangel nicht betrieben werden
kann das heißt die betten sind da die
geräte sind da die ausstattung ist da
das personal das fachpersonal fehlt
dabei sollte mit der sogenannten
pflegepersonal untergrenzen verordnung
vieles besser werden sie schreibt in der
intensiv medizin vor in der tagschicht
sollen zwei intensivpatienten von einem
pflegenden versorgt werden in der
nachtschicht drei patienten pro flieger
doch was gegen überlastung helfen sollte
funktioniert nicht in corona zeiten es
gibt zwar betten aber zu wenig personal
diese 3000 betten bei einer 12 betreuung
würde bedeuten dass 1500 pflegekräfte in
jeder schicht fähren die konsequenz ein
regelbetrieb mit zwei intensivpatienten
pro pflegekraft ist gar nicht möglich
wegen personalmangels wir treffen eine
intensiv pflegerin die allmählich an
ihrem beruf verzweifelt sie will nicht
offen vor die kamera treten wir haben
die option dass wir betten sperren
müssen dann versterben aber patienten
weil wir sie nicht versorgen können oder
wir haben die option wir lassen die
betten alle offen und dann betreut eine
pflegende so viele patienten dass die
patienten nicht so versorgt werden
können dass man tatsächlich sagt das
wäre noch alle patienten überleben weil
dann fehler passieren können und weil
eine pflegende licht in vier zimmern
gleichzeitig sein kann wenn sie vier
kurven patienten betreuen muss sie
erlebt viele intensiv pflegerinnen
können ihre arbeit nicht so machen wie
sie es gelernt haben
es ist keine pflege möglich es ist
medizin möglich und wir können die
menschen am leben halten aber es ist
keine pflege die patienten gehen danach
mit zähnen raus die mit einer adäquaten
pflege hätten nicht auftreten müssen
dass pflegekräfte fehlen ist seit jahren
bekannt die pandemie hat das problem
verschärft
eine aktuelle umfrage des deutschen
krankenhaus instituts zeigt
72 prozent der befragten haben derzeit
weniger intensiv pflegepersonal zur
verfügung als noch am ende des letzten
jahres
und 55 prozent der krankenhäuser können
intensivbetten wegen personalmangels
nicht betreiben warum hat die
bundesregierung nicht längst
gegengesteuert
erklärungsversuche des
geschäftsführenden gesundheitsministers
vergangenen freitag
wir haben den fokus in diesem bereich
jedenfalls in den letzten dreieinhalb
jahren im krankenhaus sehr sehr stark
gehabt wir haben übrigens auch so viele
auszubildende in der pflege wie noch nie
zuvor in der geschichte unseres landes
aber wir sind eben und da gibt es nichts
schönzureden wir sind noch nicht da wo
wir hin wollen und wo wir hin müssen
doch viele junge krankenpfleger kommen
erst gar nicht ins krankenhaus weil es
intensivpfleger kasten hermes aktuell
ist es ungefähr so dass in allen
ausbildungsbetrieben mit denen wir in
kontakt sind ungefähr 30 prozent der
jungen leute im ersten spätestens im
zweiten ausbildungsjahr ihrer ausbildung
niederlegen und nicht weil sie es nicht
schaffen nicht weil sie den
anforderungen nicht gewachsen sind
sondern ganz einfach weil sie sehen was
mit ihnen in der praxis passiert sie
werden nicht wirklich begleitet sie
haben keine einarbeitung keine
praxisanleitung es wird sich nicht an
feste pflegeschlüssel gehalten und das
was man ihnen beibringen müsste
außerhalb der lehrräume findet in dieser
form nicht statt und das frustriert sie
die vierte welle verschärft die krise
weiter denn immer mehr ungeimpfte landen
auf den intensivstationen
corona leutner interessiert das wenig
sie verweisen auf impf durchbrüche und
diskreditieren impfen als nutzlos
intensivmediziner janssens widerspricht
das hätte man vielleicht auch klarer
kommunizieren müssen dass wenn wir
keinen 100 prozentigen schutz vor einer
infektion haben wir haben einen 90 bis
95 prozentigen schutz vor einem schweren
krankheitsverlauf das heißt
krankenhausaufnahme und intensivstation
hätten wir die impfung nicht während der
jetzt in deutschland europaweit weltweit
schon ich sag mal ganz überspitzt
abgesoffen die gesundheitssysteme würden
zusammenbrechen vor dem hintergrund der
hochinfektiösen delta variante und der
dann folgenden belastungen für die
intensivstation die impfungen haben uns
gerettet und werden uns auch weiter
retten dennoch sieht man im berliner
krankenhaus waldfriede mit großer sorge
auf die kommenden wochen wir müssen
wegen pflegemangel 20 bis 30 betten pro
tag stern ich gehe davon aus dass in den
nächsten wochen bestimmt auch noch im
laufe des monats november überforderung
eintreten wird dadurch dass die inzidenz
zahlen steigen neben paulo zog haben
hier seit august 40 weitere pflegekräfte
aufgehört fast jeder vierte die krise
auf den intensivstationen spitzt sich im
zweiten ko-runde herbst weiter zu